was hier abgeht in diesem Bezirken im
Westteil ich nicht normal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist die Justiz nicht durchgreift das
ist das Problem wenn ich in ein anderes
Land gehe denn gelten für mich erstmal
die Maßstäbe da und nicht meine eigenen
warum muss man das so unterteilen warum
muss man sagen die schwarzköpfe sind
also wenn ich halt jetzt so einmal von
der Hermannplatz halt runter laufe das
Gefühl so ich bin irgendwie in der
Türkei auf dem Markt oder so Bergstraße
bis Hermannplatz
musst du kein Deutsch sprechen können
[Musik]
en
wir fahren Richtung sonnencenter nennt
man das Heideck Siedlung gehört auch zu
Neukölln ist aber ein bisschen abseits
von Köln so so Randbezirk mäßig also als
Jugendlicher als man da ein bisschen
aufgeschmissen finde ich weil das
einfach gar nichts ja also sie werden
sehen gefühlt nicht mein Aldi Lidl
nichts
dass viele Langeweile hat man Silvester
und einfach ein bisschen
Halligalli gemacht haben
Achmed zeigt uns das triste Ende der
Sonnenallee kurz vorm ehemaligen
Mauerstreifen
hier ging es in der Silvesternacht
besonders heiß her
auf der Straße unter den Sozialwohnungen
Ahmed und Miri sind zu alt für Böller
Schlachten feiern inzwischen ruhiger sie
erinnern sich aber das ist vor 10 Jahren
fast schon genauso heftig war es kam es
einer an meine Jugendzeit wo ich 15 16
war
wir haben uns gegenseitig gekriegt vom
Straße zur Straße jeder hat eine
Schreckschusswaffe wirklich jeder
Polizei Krankenwagen Feuerwehr nie im
Leben gemacht
Miri sieht die verrußte Fassade das
erste Mal live
also da möchte ich nicht erleben wünsche
ich auch niemandem und man hat
wahrscheinlich Angst um sein Leben und
das ist kein schönes Gefühl war
wahrscheinlich aber auch nicht so
geplant dass da ein Bus brennt und das
Gebäude auch so aussieht danach passiert
[Musik]
Krieg spielen an Silvester ein klares
Jungs Ding meint Miri als Mädchen oder
als Frau magst du das halt nicht so dass
du dann Böller Typ oder sonst was führst
das ist gibt's nicht man hat aber halt
immer zugeschaut wie die Freunde die
Cousins die Brüder die sich da mit den
Böllern unterstützen ja ja Frauen waren
nie dabei das war wirklich nur nur Jungs
Bauch geplant dafür
Ahmed und Miri sie sind kein Paar
sondern wie Bruder und Schwester er mit
palästinensisch libanesische Geschichte
sie Deutsch Türkin beide mit deutschen
passen Neukölln groß geworden das hier
ist Ghetto sagen sie ja ein Euro Shop
meistens Tot
von tanzen
wie sieht's seit 20 Jahren gleich aus
jetzt nichts verändert nichts Null ja ja
Ahmed war gut unterwegs früher so nennt
er das hat andere abgezogen also
ausgeraubt am Ende Jugendarrest mit 13
ging es los 13:14 Uhr mit 14 auch
erwischt worden zum Glück restseitig
aber bis man die Strafe bekommen hat bis
der Gerichtsprozess war früher war es
extrem langweilig als dann
soweit war
Miri arbeitet in einer Software-Firma
Ahmed ist gelernter Lkw-Fahrer Job als
Türsteher und wohnt seit drei Jahren in
Schöneberg
hobbymäßig modelt er verprüde Kurve
bekommen zum Glück habe ich in der
Schule angestrengt Realschule Abschluss
bekommen noch
Ausbildung gemacht arbeiten gegangen bei
mir auch Karriere gemacht auf Arbeit zum
Glück also mein Arbeitgeber stand mir
nicht den Weg auch wenn es ein bisschen
mir schwerer gefallen ist glaube ich
aber sonst wer will also es gibt keine
Ausreden du kommst bestimmt aus die
Frage ist die Werte die du jahrelang
hier Erlebnis alles was du gesehen
erlebt gehört hast das behältst du ja in
Dir wenn er irgendwann in Bayern wohnen
würde würde wahrscheinlich
ich kann reden wie der größte Jochen
oder so trotzdem bleibe ich da sie von
der Optiker
Neukölln für immer im Herzen und unter
der Haut wir haben eine 40 für die
Buslinie
44 ist auf die alte Postleitzahl von
Neukölln
meine verbunden hier Berlin 030 also ich
bin durch und durch Berlin und die Waffe
was soll die
steht für das gefährliche Neukölln
vier Kilometer weiter nördlich am oberen
Ende der Sonnenallee schenkt Rudi aus im
wesereck einer der letzten deutschen
Kneipen im Kiez 24 Stunden geöffnet mit
rauchgebot und ein Kümmerling von mir
wenn die anderen dir schon kein geben
daniel ist Stammgast
zu den Berliner Böller Schlachten fällt
ihm ein worüber vor ein paar Jahren kurz
vor Silvester diskutiert wurde als
gerade viele Kriegsflüchtlinge aus
Syrien ins Land kamen
weil wir sollten uns ja irgendwo so ein
bisschen
bisschen Rücksicht auf die auf die
traumatisierten Flüchtlinge nehmen
so und dieses Jahr muss die
traumatisierten Flüchtlinge mal gezeigt
was Silvester ist
Barkeeper Rudi 71 fühlt sich sauwohl in
der Sonnenallee vom Silvester Krawall
hat er so gut wie nichts mitbekommen
ich wohne ja in der arabischen Allee
[Gelächter]
okay und wie würden Sie sagen hat sich
verändert den letzten Jahren
ich habe mit den Leuten keine Probleme
die mit mir auch nicht und deswegen ich
würde hier nie wegziehen ja aber gut
Ahmed zeigt uns den lebendigsten den
arabischsten Teil der sonnenalleebt
die Gegend hier definitiv
wurde abgegeben
von meiner Mutter oder von meiner Onkelz
früher war es auch nicht so einfach als
eine Wohnung zu bekommen Neukölln war
einfacher ist wie die Türken Kreuzberg
da weiß es zu 100 Prozent dass Türken
nur Wohnungen Kreuzer bekommen haben
eine Zeit lang also ganz ganz früher
dann brauchen wir auch nicht wundern
wenn Parallelgesellschaften entstehen
seit Krieg ist in Syrien verändert sich
hier wieder viel wir haben sehr viel
aufgebaut guck mal hier die Konditorei
ist in Syrer der
shisha-ausstatter Syrer der daneben auch
Syrer und der Friseur auch die haben
echt sehr sehr schnell angefangen sich
hier
auszubreiten im positiven Sinne
einer von ihnen ist Faser
er hat einen Grillrestaurant eröffnet
zusammen mit seinem Vater und seinen
Brüdern
in bester Lage und mit den angeblich
leckersten Schawarma auf der Allee
wir sind hier in einem Straße wo man der
Beste sein will
zehn Stunden Schicht am Spießer liebt
und er weiß es zu schätzen
Deutschland hat uns auch sehr sehr sehr
viel Möglichkeiten gegeben zum Beispiel
ich habe Deutsch gelernt ich habe meinen
Ausbildung als Koch gemacht ein Adlon
Hotel wo das nicht jeder das da machen
kann also Deutschland für mich ist mein
Land
in der Silvesternacht war hier die Hölle
los drinnen Riesengeschäft draußen
Raketen Schreckschüsse und Polenböller
auf die Polizei
in Deutschland braucht Leute die fast
für Deutschland geben und nicht
Stress machen oder so was sollte man mit
denen dann machen die
Grenze
die Stadt soll das machen jeder der
Fehler macht soll bestrafbar sein dann
die Leute haben Angst und die machen das
Licht
vor Scheiße als Fenster der tägliche
Kampf
Polizeikontrollen dazu die Gestrandeten
gescheiterten die Schattenseiten der
Sonnenallee
[Musik]
brotverteiler mysil will den Ärmsten
wenigstens den Hunger stillen
weil das türkische Fernsehen ihn auch
schon mal getroffen hat verstehen wir
genauer was er macht auch ohne fließend
deutsch
muss arbeiten bei Bäckern sammelt er die
Reste ein
Hauptsache
weiter er steuert immer dieselben Orte
an
ich mache immer jeden Tag ich liege hier
Brot
auch auf den Hermannplatz am nördlichen
Ende der Sonnenallee aus Nächstenliebe
die Leute immer kommen
ich muss wieder arbeiten
einmal
17,90 € zu haben perfekt
irgendwie hatte ich Lust was Neues zu
kreieren also halt irgendwas komplett
anderes auf der Sonne die zu erschaffen
quasi so viele sagen so ich bin kleiner
hipsterladen halt so mitten drinne aber
man fällt halt auf zwischen arabischem
gardinengeschäft und türkische Bäckerei
will Valentina ihr Glück hier versuchen
vor ein paar Jahren zog sie aus dem
hessischen Fulda nach Berlin
das Café davor was hier war die sind
halt raus weil die Miete bisschen teurer
war oder teurer geworden ist und ich
hatte jetzt dann halt einfach Glück dass
ich halt wie gesagt einen guten Investor
gefunden hatte der mich halt unterstützt
und dadurch mein Budget bisschen höher
ist sonst wäre es natürlich schon
schwierig also durch die Inflation ist
natürlich ja alles extrem teuer geworden
und dann halt zu halten ist halt nicht
leicht auch Valentinas Freundinnen Mary
und Lisa-Marie finden die Sonnenallee
aufregend im Vergleich zu ihren
Heimatstädten Hamburg und Konstanz
meine erste richtige WG wo ich
mich wohl gefühlt habe war hier auf der
Sonnenallee mitten auf der Sonnenallee
mein Balkon war wirklich Richtung Straße
und da ist immer Action auf jeden Fall
aber ich glaube dieser Sicherheitsaspekt
dass hier junge Leute sich irgendwie
unwohl fühlen dass das stimmt halt gar
nicht also ich fühle mich
gesagt
Valentina will alles perfekt haben in
der Silvesternacht hätte ihr Traum vom
eigenen Café zum Albtraum werden können
wenn die Raketen ihren Laden getroffen
hätten und ihr alles abgefackelt werden
ich hätte mich auch erwischen können
soll nebenan der Weserstraße haben wir
sehr viele Läden gebrannt auch
genau
bis jetzt ging auch alles gut so bis
jetzt war noch nicht aber ja
vielleicht vor dem nächsten Semester
hier machst du ich hoffe einfach dass es
verboten wird
[Musik]
unterwegs auf der Sonnenallee
4,9 Kilometer Berlin
weniger witzig als im berühmten Kinofilm
[Musik]
aber viel mehr als nur Drama und crime